Bonjour, je m'appelle Lucas, j'ai 24 ans et
aujourd'hui je vais vous montrer comment gagner plus de 20 000€ par jour
Dans un jeu vidéo uniquement par contre
Huniecam Studio c'est un jeu dans lequel on monte un cam-studio
Voilà. Me demandez pas ce que c'est, j'en ai absolument rien à foutre et je ne sais pas.
A en déduire par le nombre de poitrine qu'on voit juste dans les écrans de chargement et d'accueil
de ce p*tain de jeu
on va employer des filles pour gagner de l'argent.
"Parmis ces filles laquelle attire ton attention ?"
Tiffany, Nikki ou Kyanna ?
Y a une fille qui est fine, y a une fille qui a des lunettes et des gros seins et y a une latina qui a des grosses fesses.
Ça, ça met direct les points sur les "i"
On va prendre le gros CUL latina *rire*
C'est d'une violence
En plus il y en a aucune qui fume et qui boit
C'est splendide
Elle va nous rapporter 1$/heure pour finalement
arnaquer des hommes sur des sites de rencontre.
Donc il faut la prendre et la mettre en mode "Tu bosses"
Allez gros cul
Faisons-lui faire un rapide... un skype quoi, hein
On la prend et on la met dans le studio
Ensuite on a juste à cliquer sur le building pour gagner euh... les sous
qu'elle a généré
5 dollars ?!
Attend pour une latina aux grosses fesses euuuuhh....
C'est cher le Skype *rire*
On a besoin de fans
Ah, on va faire un shooting photo. C'est malin ça !
Alors... Ok elle est au photo studio
On a eu un shooting
Et du coup là on collecte des fans, c'est génial !
Ok c'est parti ! Là la meuf qui fait le tuto euh... m'a tout appris
Bah d'ailleurs pourquoi elle fait pas ça elle-même plutôt que de m'apprendre
Elle est débile ! Elle pourrait faire fortune
Alors toi on va te faire travailler
Ensuite est-ce qu'on peut pas avoir des nouvelles filles ?
Nan il y a pas moyen ?
C'est où pour acheter des filles ? *rire*
C'est ultra glauque mais en fait c'est un simulateur de mafieux ce jeu.
Alors on a 12 fans euh... du gros cul et 3 fans du genre Latina
J'vous comprends les mecs, j'vous comprends
Alors on a Zoey, Béli ou Nikki
Beli c'est une Asiatique, chubby je sais pas ce que ça veut dire,
Flat chest *rire*
On va prendre la femme aux gros seins
Comme ça on a de tout
C'est très bien ça, c'est très bien. Putain on ferait un excellent mafieux
Toi tu vas aller travailler bordel là au lieu de rien faire
J'la fais travailler comme un enculé
Alors Zoey, Nadia, Laila-
OH IL Y A UNE MILF AVEC DES TATOUAGES !!!
Le truc hyper ciblé !
J'suis sûr que tu auras des fans de milf avec tatouages
Allez on la recrute
Faites-nous du putain d'argent !
Faites-nous de la thune bordel de merde !
Alors lunettes aux gros seins on va te faire avoir plus de fans
en faisant un petit shooting photo
Alors au niveau des fans :
Ils adorent surtout les gros culs
Bon bo-
Les lunettes !
Ah les vieux pervers bizarres
Les MILFS 20% et les gros seins 15% seulement
J'aurais dit plus, on apprend des choses
Faites de l'argeeeeent !!!
Allez ! Skypez, Skypez ! Chauffez les mecs, chauffez les mecs
Demandez-leur 20 allow pass juste pour leur montrer votre doigt
Moi je pense qu'on devrait ramener Nadya la MILF
Nan mais c'est vrai
Elle on va en faire une star, mon gars.
Elle va faire plein plein plein de shootings photo, ça va cartonner.
Ahh putain, elles ont une barre de stress les filles !!
Et plus elles sont stressées et plus il faut les mettre au repos
En même temps mec j'avoue on leur fait faire des Skype 24h/24 quoi
On est en train d'arnaquer tous les mecs de Coco.fr
*Rire*
Allez toi tu vas aller au spa
Vas-y, détend-toi au spa
On leur paye le spa quand même ! On est cool mon gars, hein.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter ?
Alors attends faut les payer.
32 $ putain on les paye cher, hein !
Nan j'avoue on se fait des bénéfices de malade
Alors au niveau des pronostics qui est... où on en est ?
Oh putain la MILF est passée devant les tatouages !!
Le cul se retrouve en 3ème position
Putain j'comprends plus rien
Les goûts sexuels des mecs ça varie comme les couleurs, c'est n'importe quoi !
D'accord on peut envoyer des filles au club de striptease
Et elle gagnera des points de talent.
Allez on va recruter une fille qui sera une MILF, qui aura des tatouages et qui aura des lunettes.
La totale !
Ce sera notre poule aux oeufs d'or, putain...
Alors Beli, Lola, Zoey
Oh Lola putain elle est talentueuse
Elle est fit, ebony.
Ebola elle a du skill de ouf !
Lola pardon !
Ebola... *rire*
N'importe quoi.
On va prendre Lola, mec.
Lola tu vas remplacer femme aux lunettes.
Putain elle rapporte tellement de fans elle, mon gars !
C'es exceptionnel !
Elle a déjà 52 fans quoi ! Putain elle a trop de succès, c'est incroyable !
La MILF on va te mettre au truc de striptease,
Toi on va te faire faire un peu de shopping.
Putain le stripclub c'est méga long, mon gars !
Elle y reste 72 heures, quoi !
Elle finit elle a même plus de peau tellement elle a retiré ses vêtements.
C'est drôle ça, on s'amuse !
Alors le Stripclub ça m'a fait gagner des notes de musique, je sais pas ce que c'est
Ah si c'est, OK c'est du skill
Ah si j'ai une meuf agée elle aura encore plus de skill, c'est super.
Au lieu de montrer un doigt pour 5€ elle montrera 2 doigtrs de sa main comme ça.
Oh putain toute la thune qu'on a gagné, mon gars, c'est incroyable !
D'accord ! Donc en fait j'ai des filles qui boivent et qui fument, du coup elles stressent moins,
Mais dès qu'elles ont plus de clopes ou d'alcool elles stressent comme des oufs.
Donc faut que j'envoie quelqu'un aller acheter de l'alcool ou des clopes.
Putain mais c'est super glauque, mec...
Alors au niveau des fans, ça en est où les pronostics ?
Fit, ils aiment bien les meufs fit maintenant. Bah comme elle voilà, la poule aux œufs d'or.
Ebony, bah comme elle, voilà, la poule aux œufs d'or.
Les MILFs ?! Ah les MILFs ont toujours un peu de succès.
Les tatouages, ah tatouages aussi !
Les gros culs et les gros seins ça a toujours pas de succès c'est incroyable.
Alors est-ce que j'ai de quoi vous payer ?
Toujours pas je suis désolé...
J'suis désolé, j'suis un connard.
En plus elles sont toutes stressées là, comme des oufs.
Alors on va toutes vous faire bosser un coup
et avec les sous j'vais vous payer et toutes vous envoyer au spa.
Petit spa pour toi et toi
Et toi tu vas faire des fans !
Il nous faut des abonnés ! *rire*
Que quand ils se connectent ils aient déjà 10 allow pass à nous filer juste pour qu'on mette notre cam'.
Alors que dans tous les     il y a pas un bout de chair qui dépasse.
On est des putain d'escrocs, il faut bien se mettre ça dans le crâne !
Ce jeu est génial, j'suis en pleine addiction
Mais j'ai un peu le     et qui me demande à quoi il joue j'aurai l'air hyper con
Ecoute j'suis un putain de mafieux là il y a des meufs qui font des Skype
J'les paye à 1/4 de ce que ça me rapporte
J'suis un fils de pute !
P'tain on va manquer de clope et de euuh... et d'alcool là, c'est chaud !
Eh vous êtes chiantes à boire et à fumer. Vous voulez pas arrêter ? C'est une perte d'argent et de temps pour moi en tant que mafieux.
S'il vous plaît les filles.
J'fais tout pour vous, j'suis hyper gentil et vous vous en battez les couilles...
Ah meeerde j'suis endetté !
J'suis à -58
Si j'reste dans le rouge plus de 24 heures j'vais être viré mais naan ?!
"Eh j'suis un mafieux, tu m'vires pas comme ça !"
Faut générer de la thune sinon la boss du dessus il va me virer
Bon c'est une petite fille de 6 ans Kawaii mais bon on sait jamais.
Oooohhh j'suis dans le rooouge de ouf, mon gars !
J'suis à -220 *rire*
En fait là pù je perds de la thune c'est quand je les envoie acheter des putain de clopes.
J'peux pas envoyer un larbin acheter des clopes plutôt qu'elles là ? C'est les stars du site bordel
Ok on va faire de la promo. On va acheter euh... 16 fans !
Et 21 et 23 !
On s'est endetté comme des fils de pute mais on a un max de fans !
On est mort ! ON EST MORT ! J'me suis endetté comme une merde !
On peut pas faire un crédit s'il vous plaît ?
Mais elle génèreront jamais assez de thune, elles sont au spa !
En fait j'aurais pas dû recruter 3 filles dès le début, ça m'a tué putain...
Oh j'suis dans la merde...
Si j'suis toujours en négatif au bout de 24 heures j'suis mort.
Ooooh j'suis dans la merde de partout quoi...
Il y a plus d'alcool, il y a plus d'argent, il y a plus rien...
Plus de passion, il y a plus de passion dans ce qu'on fait. C'est ça qui nous mène à la fin *rire*
AAAHH ! C'est bon.
Par contre quand la paye va tomber ça va faire très très mal...
J'suis toujours en négatif, mec, hein, j'suis toujours dans la merde, hein.
Putain mais j'men sors pas !
Faites de l'argent, faites de l'argent, faites de l'argent !
Demandez plus de Allow Pass, toujours plus !
Ooooohhhhh !!
La dette elle est de plus en plus grosse, mec, j'suis tellement dans la meeeeeerde !!
J'crois que c'est la fin d'un business putain. J'étais en train de try hard mais là le crédit on le remboursera jamais à temps, mec...
En plus on a pris un taux à intérêt variable. Ça va... putain là le marché il est pas bon.
Quelle journée de merde pour un mafieux, bordel de merde...
P'tain elle a zéro fans elle, faut la remplacer la MILF elle est périmée !
Elle a vieilli entre temps c'est plus une MILF c'est une grand-mère maintenant.
Ok alors on a le choix entre quoi ? Entre Sarah, Beli et Tiffany.
Alors attends ils aiment quoi les gens en ce moment ?
Ils aiment tout ce qui est fit !
Tiffany viens avec nous, Tiffany !
On va faire de grandes choses ensemble, Tiffany.
OOh ! -1 300 ! On est endetté jusqu'à la mort, j'avais pas vu !
On est mort !
Allez les filles là, faites des cam', faites des cam' là !!
Prenez que 2 Allow Pass au lieu de 3 pour montrer votre doigt, c'est pas grave.
Oh j'suis dans la merde ! J'suis dans une merde de mafieux mon pote !
P'tain c'est chaud il est 20h00 dans le jeu on a jusqu'à-
On a- il nous reste que 4 heures !!
On est mort... En plus regardez elle mettent de plus en plus de temps à obtenir des sous des gens.
Les gens ils ont compris qu'il y avait de l'arnaque sur ce site. Maintenant ils arrêtent d'y aller.
Nan déstressez ! Va à ton p'tit spa !
T'façons ça fait faillite alors mets-toi bien au spa,
Quand tu reviendras t'auras plus de métier, ce sera fini.
'Fin un métier....
Oooh on dirait que ça s'est mal passé. Tu es dans le rouge depuis 24 heures.
Honnêtement je comprends pas trop comment tu as pû foirer.
On s'est tous donné pour le bien de ce projet et tu as actuellement tout fait foirer
Ok.
Mais écoute c'est pas la fin du monde, essaie une nouvelle fois, j'suis sûre que tu feras mieux.
Comment ça essaie une nouvelle fois ?!
Aaaaah ça nous réconforte là c'est-oouuhh ça nous réconforte oui.
Comment ça une nouvelle chance ?! On s'est endetté comme des porcs auprès de la banque,
Les filles elles veulent plus de moi, elles sont là, elles ont fumé 600 clopes, elles ont bu 20 verres de Whiskey.
Et bah voilà on fera jamais un bon mafieux,
On pue la merde !
Bon soyons honnêtes on s'en bat les steaks d'être un mauvais mafieux.
Allez on se retrouve dans une prochaine vidéo! Merci d'avoir regardé. Portez vous bien. Ciao tout le monde !
PEACE !